hey guys what's up welcome to Gotham
comedy live let's hear it I see
alright man alright some of you guys are
legitimately try and record this with
your phones you know it's on [ __ ] TV
you don't have to do that people will
believe you were here you know that no
one's gonna be like oh yeah I knows on
TV let me see your [ __ ] Instagram
though okay you're really there you're
really there what up guys everybody good
or what got [ __ ] did you do yours
you're so close to me right now
and I'm so close to you you yeah I don't
like guys like you because you have
[ __ ] your hair your face hair is
longer than your [ __ ] hair hair
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] this guy I don't
like that at all trim it and let it you
know if this is going just [ __ ] get
rid of it to it do you know I mean you
got like upside-down head or some [ __ ]
hahaha this is you before you go out
tonight you won't like this it's cool
man
that's the way to be right there long
[ __ ] what good
why are you splitting it like you [ __ ]
him or something long broom hair and
then trim trim trim you know what I mean
keeping it short but not but [ __ ]
long nice bro I like that
you're looking at me literally like you
would look at like the Mona Lisa or some
[ __ ] no laughing at all just like this
and see what they were trying to do I
see what they were trying to do I'm a
[ __ ] idiot I hate I hate museums I
can't go people love looking at [ __ ]
paintings they do then they pretend even
if they don't they pretend you know what
I mean they're just they're [ __ ]
staring close to they'll just [ __ ] I
see I see what they're trying to do here
I see they'll spend 40 minutes looking
at [ __ ] George Washington every
museum I've ever been to this is how I
look at every painting right here I go
like this I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't care I don't care if
your painting is from 1740 I don't give
a [ __ ] I got like this cool cool cool
all right some some artists back there
huh cool man
ah this guy right here you look like me
after it's like the after me that's cool
what's your name like Chad or some [ __ ]
got what
Kosta Kosta as if the hair isn't sexy
enough it's not even cool star you'd
even say oh I'm getting you bro I'm
getting you man yeah no back back back -
he's like I see I see what they were
trying to do there I see Costa Costa
it's just [ __ ] Kosta [ __ ] you know
I mean Bob Costas Bob Costas
basta basta with the long hair who you
would do with three dudes just on the on
the prowl three dudes on the prowl you
all look like [ __ ] versions of each
other you guys all literally if you
stood if you guys stood in a line this
way it would be like the [ __ ]
evolution chart ha ha ha bro you would
be at the end you know that [ __ ] come on
you know you would be at the end you
know you would be at the end and
everybody dude everybody everybody would
be walking like this except for ghosts
that would be like this with this
[ __ ] dick just flopping like this bro
you do not laugh man you doesn't laugh
that's what you're doing
look at me with them you got it - you'd
be right right after Costa you'd be
right after Costa but what's your name
though been the non sexy version of
Costa everybody the non sexy surfer
version of Costa you checking him out
bro
okay okay still super interested not
laughing all right I see how you can say
that I see
were you guys from well you guys all
look like extras from that movie Munich
Queens okay all right cool
easy is easy for [ __ ] Queens
who's got the sexiest name who the guy
races I like other guy this better be
[ __ ] sexy as [ __ ] okay I mean I just
talking to dude Costa there's four of
you and I say who has the sexiest name
without even blinking
this guy just goes like this what's your
name [ __ ] cuddling guess what is it
what is it Vasily ops
miss that's [ __ ] his last name is
steal your girl that's what it is
my name is Vashti Leo steal your girl
but Stelios it's actually on the way to
saying that but steal your girl
that's [ __ ] my name is Vasily Oscar
that's [ __ ] hilarious I like how your
mom was probably like named um Jimmy you
know and then and then your dad is like
you do not understand
you see his dick you see them
he's already big it is the size of a toy
car and he is only a child what if he
hangs out with four men and one of them
has a sexier name than him like I don't
know Costa
what shall we name him something like no
no no that is that is too strong come on
Tommy no no no no no no no no I cannot
it is way way way too sexy I want to
know it is my son okay I will tell you
but first doctor can we have a tower
piece put it under her
sit down on this towel you are my wife
and I love you but sit down on this
towel okay what is it the name my
beloved wife is vest Ilyas